[Music]
in Banksy edie news Banksy Banksy this
Banksy he's a stencil artist supposed to
be ie D oh yeah true looks like Banksy
education news submitted by what rhymes
with will do mildew it's actually think
will will dope oh my god can you read
David
well yes I can there's there's two elves
in it
I will though like dildo like a will
dough but he said will do if it was
dildo you should have only wrote one
right then they submitted it well then
how do you know that they're trying
they're trying to get us a soap dildo
they say still though or still ho ho
argue about that live happy now
submitter thank ya thanks a lot you
[ __ ] dildo pill row a bang see
painting self-destructed right after
being auctioned for over 1 million I saw
this it shows crazy
that's tight son does that mean Banksy
was in the room that's the people
someone was in the room yeah people
think that there was just like hooded
man who was like talking to the cops
after he was laughing he was the one
that stupid did it light on fire
no I'm not gonna ruin it that's the
video this sold for 1.1 million dollars
that's kind of funny I know that was his
not on his IG
a few years ago I secretly built the
shredder into a painting he's a
craftsman he knows how to make eyelashes
it was ever put up for auction
Sotheby's
[Applause]
so tender
the whole room shocked
I'd be shocked too I love it they know I
want to know how they stopped it how did
it trigger someone was there or people
think that like it's a remote control
poverty high cuz they're saying that
this hooded dude he had like a Ramon he
like did something does the person who
won the million still have to pay or
paid the million you know there isn't
that one option the person who won it
like they're actually thankful because
they soared more now they think that
they've doubled the price oh yeah of it
by shredding it yeah because this is
like it's like history yeah this is like
art history in the making like there
that's true no one has ever done this
before a immediately self-destruction
that's like the best troll move in the
world this was acquired by the auction
house in 2006 I wonder if the battery
can really last that long that's what
people read is this someone set it up
they had to set it up that's someone
someone was in on it
like what battery did you use that
lasted this long but the person who
bought it they're saying it doubled but
then other people are saying nah that
thing's worth like less than a dollar
and wash it for now but literally like
40 years from now that's just gonna be
ridiculous oh yeah it's true it's
shredded clean right if piece of backup
together
it's fine I would leave it as it with it
dangling it looks dope and it's not half
way to leave it like that like you're
looking for roommates it looks like art
it looks like and you are yeah yeah
number yeah each each a shredder
whatever
oh it's dope like that like a million
dollars each when I heard blew up as an
artist because I want that to [ __ ]
disappear because I was thinking the
whole time
people are gonna bid bid bid and then
the last person that bids they pay for
it
and it self-destructs and burns into
shreds and you can't even have anything
it's just air they would have been dope
if it was like acid they're just kind of
like yeah everything yeah the guy's just
going
yeah they lost all their money and
that's the art piece right there yeah
it's like you put everything into it
you're just witnessing [ __ ] I could
see this in Las Vegas all the time but
you're witnessing a person lose their
fortune on this [ __ ] they did say though
that like usually in auctions and stuff
if something happens to the piece that
was bought and that it'll just like be
canceled oh they paid for that
experience yeah they did pity pain
sadness they have to deliver the artwork
as it was as it's being auctioned right
so but I wonder in I guess in this case
he's just like no give it to me how did
he even get a head like their hands on
it because I know he doesn't ever want
to sell his stuff so how did he has
someone that that does this for him oh
really yeah like he'll control that I
saw this one documentary and I remember
in that documentary there was like a
person like a middleman that they
actually talked to other like auction
people to help keep him anonymous yeah
last time you know for the longest time
I didn't really understand like why
certain things cost so much and I get it
now like if it's a Rembrandt or some
kind of like classical artist that was
like it's a piece of history or whatever
but then like modern art and and other
other stuff I found out that a part of
the art world is also a way for wealthy
people to hold on to money and they do
it in a way that's really [ __ ] clever
let's say all of us are friends and we
really rich friends okay okay and then
let's say I say there for us we trust
that jess is a really great artist right
and then she'll make a [ __ ] stick
figure so make this right and it will go
oh hey I think this is worth three
million don't you David and you're like
yeah I do
and I'm like mmm you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna pay my friend three million
now this is worth three million
but dude since all of the stuff that
you've helped me do throughout the years
I'm gonna give you this as a gift so now
this is a deductible for me you hold on
to it and in
anytime in the future you could pass off
to Bart now this three million or now
you could call it five you give that to
Bart and it just keeps circling like
this so it's another way for rich people
to circle around wealth and it holds on
to that there's a maximum light
deduction on taxes it's like fifteen
thousand dollars yeah it's not always
written all outs gives it could be a
transfer of wealth and value so it's not
quote-unquote a gift right so it's like
instead of like paying me money for the
company that you're gonna buy oh well
how about you trade me like three of
those Mozart's plus this special maracas
plus like two million dollars okay but
if enough people believe and agree that
this is that much we could do it that
way too well within our circle how much
would you guys pay me for that painting
over there you give me money to take
that [ __ ] no I would take that and I
would slice it in half an hour throw it
in the trash yeah that's kind of a nice
table that is thank you stopping to take
a picture of it rip in the trash and now
that the picture finish it you bastard
how about that it's finished in the eyes
of the chef but I mean I like how its
unfinished finished that's just what it
is
yeah there's no Sun glass there's
nothing we need to get a close-up shots
as we keep talking about that so I'm
gonna go bring it and show it to him I'm
[ __ ] let me show you guys this [ __ ]
don't look at David's but no that's okay
that shit's its price right you're
supposed to wear gloves dude all your
oils are gonna get on it
oh no it's worth more has David's oil
it's a pencil mark hey this is my first
one I gotta make sure I don't [ __ ] up
look at this like how he spit in the
lines though you actually made a grid to
draw that know how hard was you reading
grid to drum draw that [ __ ] was hard
yeah I'll put it to you right now okay
everybody out of the comments this
painting is gonna start at $4,000 that's
it that's how we're gonna pay for the
movie for Mellon
400 thousand a million damn when you
find a thousand from the movie okay I'm
trying to be somewhat realistic let's
start with $40 arts never better I think
that good sell for like 300 300 what
about a super rich a die-hard take it
then $100 our grids here bro do you the
great sport yeah it's like you ignored
them
I was shining them never Simon that's
true yeah what what medium did you use
okay
Alec it's acrylic it's a pencil grip
maybe if you let take a finish it it'll
be worth Oh
would that be cool you like this way
more to me what happened here so you
dumped a whole bunch of paint here and
then you scraped it out for the the
paint no that was just a base layer and
then I was dumping paints I can make it
look all like like molten yeah would you
put it to be flat right here it's so
square God actually I might have picked
it out yeah it seems like he got the
other end of the paintbrush well guys
this is gonna start at geo says three
hundred three hundred dollars so if you
guys want to get this painting for $300
please go to my paypal and what if
people start sending you money it's not
for sale I go to my bed mommy in the
comments below
start a bidding war the highest bid wins
no we're not gonna get rid of it just
for fun four five how about $4,000 nope
for 400,000 lost your [ __ ] mind dude
40,000 all right
[Music]